our next guest is a legend and the only
black woman to be an egot winner she is
a force of nature entertaining any room
she walks into and she has a brand new
holiday collection and some of our
audience members are already rocking it
and in the spirit
i can't wait to ask her all her thoughts
and all her feelings on christmas ladies
and gentlemen please welcome the one the
only
whoopi goldberg
[Applause]
thank god i know cause what
[Applause]
just so you know i have known whoopee
since i was eight years old
um we met on the set of the color purple
yes we did yes we did
so funny
i was visiting um steven spielberg and i
came on set and hung out for a few days
and i got to meet you for the very first
time we've known each other our whole
life yeah well
a lot of your life yes that's true yeah
yeah but you and my kid are the same age
so yeah she's you know it's just a
family it's a family affair it is a
family
i i didn't know this story about
alice walker sending
stephen to see you somewhere i wrote to
alice walker on my way to new york who
wrote the color purple wrote the color
purple so i wrote her a letter and said
listen if they ever make a movie i would
like to play the dust on the floor
and i got to new york to do the first
run of my um
one-person show and there was a letter
waiting for me in the projects that said
um by the way
i've seen all of your shows i already
know who you are i've sent your stuff to
stephen and quincy
i was like stephen and quincy stephen
and quincy who stephen and
and then my mother said well maybe
spielberg and jones right
i was like oh
okay that would be cool and then
probably forgot about it
and did he come
no i went to him i went to amblyn okay
yes and uh
he said i i wasn't able to get to new
york but i would love it if you could do
your show here i was like okay he said
i've invited some friends i said oh okay
audiences are good gosh what did he
bring so i'm standing behind the curtain
and i'm looking
and i think
wait a minute is that michael jackson
oh my god is that ashford and simpson oh
my gosh oh this is really fun
wednesday
oh my god oh my god okay and then i
stopped looking because i thought if i
see one more thing i'm going to pass out
yeah
and then i did the show and and
they all loved it and then they said
more
and i said i'm not supposed to do
anymore.
and stephen said
well why why not i said well because i i
i did this thing called bli tea
and blee tea is blacky tea yes
and the elliot that he meets up with is
living in the projects like i grew up in
uh-huh
and he said well you know i want to see
it now and i was like well they told me
not to do it for you
they said i shouldn't do it and he said
don't do it
and all i could hear was everybody
saying don't do it for him
and he said but i would like to see it
and i'm thinking okay what can i do
so i did it
and he laughed and fell on the floor
because because
it really it was about
what happens when you assimilate because
that's what e.t does and so bliti
doesn't recognize his people when they
come back for them so he has decided
he's running you know he's running girls
and he's hanging with them yeah all kind
of stuff
and didn't he couldn't phone home he
couldn't find home because nothing was
working right
so that was one of the things and it was
all about
him assimilating to the point where he
didn't recognize his people when they
came back for it so that was
kind of what i did
so you took the red i took the win and
it paid off it also shows the power of
writing a letter if you hadn't written
to alice yeah now when we we did boys on
this we made a film called boys on the
side together back in the day yeah
it's like it's just it's still it still
holds up it's it's it's a sweet movie
it's a beautiful movie and we had the
best time making it yes
the best it just doesn't get better than
you me mary louise parker squeeze parker
road tripping around the country look at
us oh my gosh we're in several states
and location directed by the incredible
herbert ross yes who's no longer with us
who was just an extraordinary filmmaker
there was a new actor he kept bragging
to us about saying you have got to check
this guy out i found him i've discovered
him he's been in like one or two movies
and it's matthew mcconaughey
yeah
yeah who knew
and
his illustrious career that has thus
then followed although i was i'm not
gonna lie i was really upset when i
heard he wasn't gonna run for governor
of texas like the other day
well
you know
i kind of like the idea that it might be
a good idea to put government in the
hands of a couple of
folks who actually have a
a good idea of how it should go
and then
you know and then invite the newbies in
and then mix them up so they get an idea
of how it should be or how it could be
or how it could be better
not worse
i don't want any more of this you know
you're an idiot and i'm not
you know i don't want it anymore i don't
i don't want it
kind of why i got excited about matthew
mcconaughey i thought he's such a
like peaceful dude right and he kind of
has so much good will that maybe he
would just good willis into some sanity
no unfortunately he actually has to have
some policies
you know it's i know it's crazy but he's
gotta you know he's gotta find a way to
to
make texans feel like texas is there
but he stays oh texas and he's a
diplomatic person and i thought maybe he
could bring some common ground because
everything you just said is the problem
the no common ground the we are
different but we can allow each other to
live yes that would be nice i miss that
i feel like i've gotten really old
because i like the idea of you know
saying well i don't know if i agree with
that let me think about it what do you
want to eat you know that's that's
remember we used to do that and it
wasn't like you weren't pointing fingers
and screaming at people i don't want to
scream i don't want to i don't mind
talking i don't mind disagreeing but at
this when it becomes personal it's just
not cool you know that's why i can't i
agree i can't agree i agree
which is why i wanted him to step in and
say alright alright
[Music]